the love of a father first children is
differently loved husband for his wife
of a congregant for his god but I have
the joy of all of those and it's not
like pornography like i'll tell you when
i when i find it it's almost palpable
it's almost sensory there is an
unconditional pneus to the love that I
pray would become the standard for the
love of every parent for his or her
child not unconditional in a bind sense
but unconditional in an na na it comes
from our infinite place and it's
inexhaustible the love of the husband
for for his wife is a mixture of awe and
fear and joy and the the love of the
congregant for for the divine is silent
and stupefied and breathless and and so
overwhelming that it's that it goes
downwards